on est en approche
briquet
notre convoi attention à 15
voir ces gamins et en difficulté dégage
boulot sur la haine la noce
le protégerait contre câble est tout
seul je peux pas faut du renfort
on va former un super méga groupe mais
on va refaire un tour sur linkedin
je te présente bedlam je m'appelle
shatter star domino j'ai de la chance la
chance se paraît super pouvoir écouter
sinon
mais si on n'a qu'à couper la poire en
deux c'est non aller en piste
donc moi
m'exprimer
départ au vatican et qui sait en jouer
tellement d'arc
tu es sûr que tu viens pas de l'univers
dc comics
[Musique]
il
gros jeu wii le bordel
tu de tes balles elles sont rapides
maintenant pour couronner le tout peter
un super pouvoir quelconque je sais pas
nager pas de pouvoir non j'ai vu
l'annoncé voilà tel poste
[Musique]